What a farm 'tastic day!
Meet Otis the tractor.
It's time to get going and
do some crowing!
Cock 'a doodle doo!
Otis lives on Longhill
dairy farm.
And he knows when someone
has a problem...
I can't open the door.
There's only one thing to do.
Stop...
Hit the brakes!
...and help!
I have to get to the high jump competition!
Let's get rolling!
Otis!
Woo hoo!
Otis, you did it! You got us out!
♫ Otis! Otis! ♫
I'm stuck!
Because having a
big heart...
♫ When he feels his heart glowing ♫
...means being ready
to lend a hand.
I'll catch you!
Ooof!
♫ Together on the farm... ♫
We did it!
And when everyone
looks out for one another...
Go Otis, go!
Woo hoo!
It makes this farm
even better.
It's Oinks-Cellent!
Can I help you get down?
Thank you Otis.
This wigglings got
me giggling.
Help!
Kevin, can you toss me
your tow line?
Just keep holding
on Celeste!
Let's go!
I'm out!
On this farm, we all help each other.
That's a hundred percent
genuine farm fact.
Yeah!
♫ So let's get rolling with Otis ♫